[Music]
the undisputed highlight of the monster
verse will be published next year and
will be called
godzilla vs kong as deadline and the
hollywood reporter now report the movie
is netflix worth
200 million us dollars and of course
includes exclusive publishing rights for
the streaming service
the latest news is that warner has
turned down the offer and may be
planning to show the blockbuster
simultaneously on his own streaming
service
hbo max and in the cinema similar to
wonder woman 1984 which will be released
in december
but since three quarters of the film
belongs to the production company
legendary which in turn is a subsidiary
of the chinese wonder group
and they want to see money from it
warner could get into a quandary with
this model and despite his own plans
have to close
the deal with netflix rather complicated
situation which will certainly
also depend on the success of wonder
woman 1984.
how do you see that would you rather see
the movie exclusively on netflix or
do you simply need the cinematic
experience for the spectacular
blockbuster
write it down in the comments even ryan
reynolds wasn't sure
after the disney takeover of 20th
century fox whether a third death will
film could be expected in the future
surprisingly however there's good news
for the large deadpool fan community
because this variety reports the two
sisters wendy and lizzy molyneux
were hired as screenwriters until now
they were known mainly as executive
producers of the animation series of
bob's burgers
so the humor seems to be in line with
the deadpool franchise
of course this doesn't mean that the
third offshoot will suddenly become
youth friendly since variety assumes
based on reliable sources
that a much hotter rating is planned
again rob liefeld the creator of the
film series
must nevertheless dampen the joy of many
fans a bit because
even under perfect conditions completion
would take at least two years after the
start of shooting
and of course tends to take longer still
lehel sounds much more optimistic
in may he was still talking about the
fact that there will be no reunion with
deadpool for the next 5 years
in any case we hope that the standstill
on deadpool 3 will soon come to an
end and then we can surprise you with
more positive news in the near future
cherry is the name of the next film by
the russo brothers who directed avengers
end game
after several engagements in various mcu
movies and the most successful movies of
all times
they now dedicate themselves to project
of their heart the content of cherry is
about nico walker a former soldier who
became a bank robber afterwards
and processes experience a novel called
cherry a central theme is the
post-traumatic stress disorder of the
young walker who gets into money
troubles due to his resulting opioid
addiction
the russo brothers were so enthusiastic
about this story that they used their
own money to secure the rights in a
bitter contest with the other major
interested parties
in tom holland they've also found an old
acquaintance for the role of nico
walker with kiara bravo and nicole
forrester also involved
by the way apple tv plus has secured the
streaming rights where the film is
scheduled to release on march 12
2021 in addition a cinema release is
planned for february 26th but how
exactly this will be handled outside the
usa
is not yet clear the predator series is
one of the most popular alien franchises
in the film world
since the predator could not achieve the
hope for success and disney now really
does not stand for brutal alien action
fans did not expect too much from a
potential predator 5.
as discussing film reported at the end
of last year director dan trachtenberg
and screenwriter patrick ayson have been
working on a project called
skulls for quite some time logically
after all the predator collects the
skills of his victims
as has now become known the upcoming
film unlike its predecessors is intended
to play in the past and not in the
present
or future allegedly this time an
american native is the center of
attention
which is not surprising because as we
know since alien vs predator
the aliens have been using the earth as
a hunting ground for a long time
a right and important impulse for the
dormant franchise
at least 10 cloverfield lane director
dan trachtenberg is not at all amused on
twitter about the leak which was
actually planned as a surprise
we'll hopefully soon find out what other
surprises trackenberg who according to
his own statement has been working on
predator for four years
has planned after a lot of back and
forth it's finally clear
max mickelson plays the evil wizard
galat grindelwald in the new fantastic
beasts part
not really surprising although mickelson
pretended to know nothing last week
now both sides should be satisfied
because on the one hand he was the top
favorite of director david yates
on the other hand the dane is more than
familiar with the role of the villain as
you could see in casino royale
dr strange and of course hannibal above
all the series about the cannibal dr
hannibal actor which was discontinued in
2015
ensured the 55 year old a loyal fan base
we are definitely curious to see how
mickelson will adapt the role of
grindelwald and are looking forward to
fantastic beasts 3 on july 15
2022 since the death of chadwick boseman
there were some uncertainties about the
future of black panther 2.
now it seems to be certain when the
studio will start shooting
in fact next year per hollywood reporter
the production will start in atlanta in
july 2021
if the shooting isn't interrupted it's
expected to take six months until a
completion
furthermore there are new additions as
narcos mexico actor
tenna cueta is supposed to play one of
the villains in the new mcu movie
as we reported last week marvel won't be
replacing chadwick boseman with a
digital double
which character instead will slip into
his superhero suit
will unfortunately still cannot estimate
at this point
an official release date is not known
but the release in 2022
seems realistic
[Music]
bye